huh you know well you think about all
the as far as i'm as if i might be i'm
wrong about this but i'm pretty sure all
the head offices of
instagram facebook youtube twitter are
all within a few mile radius of each
other in san francisco they're on
silicon valley of course
you know that they're on a group chat
yeah like you know they're on a group to
like come on yeah think about it like
i'm sure you
tate fresh and fit justin waller are on
a group check because that's your squad
that's your crew me pat mario we're on a
group chat you know that the big tech
companies whoever's running twitter
these days facebook mark zuckerberg
whoever's running tick tock in america
like you're on a group chat what's up
dinner this tuesday night hey guys just
canceled andrew tate whatever oh [ __ ]
what do you think
they have
that's their squad yeah
yeah and they they don't care if you're
black or white or asian or whatever it
may be they're in it for the money yeah
and so yeah they are all in competition
but they all probably have the same
political agenda i would imagine
i think they do go ahead but if they're
in competition wouldn't
wouldn't one want to keep them because
they would get all of the views well one
has rumble
and and also yeah but all the rumble
and uh parlor and um these these are
these are
this these are like the b this is the b
squad yeah yeah okay this is this is the
b squad look this is i i'm not gonna sit
here and pretend i'm privy to andrew's
entire plan uh
but this we have currently just gotten
through gone through part one of a
three-part plan that andrew has
according to his video that was part
that was actually part one
so a big when you have a
andrew's literally the most googled man
on the planet right now that's right
which i think is so genuine i love that
but i think one of the biggest one of
the most powerful things that andrew is
trying to do right now and if if he
pulls it off this will be this will be
game changing is
because he has the the public's
attention right now
he has now moved him his his social
media presence on to rumble and ghetto
rumble and gathering
right if andrew can move
giant swathes of the population onto
these platforms well that breaks up the
monopoly
that all these big social media
companies have yeah if you can actually
cause a really significant shift that's
powerful i agree with you
it's not going to work though like why
wouldn't a big company want that because
they're they're all
in this couch like all of them they all
have the same ideology and their
ideologies and they're not competition
too but their ideology is not based
around free speech so if you like that
clip click right here to watch another
or if you want to watch the entire sauce
cast click right here
[Music]